this is my way of living and nobody's
gonna tell me any otherwise can we talk
about your husband and tiger king can we
just talk about tiger king for a second
you think it's him
you think it's got to be him we talked
to John Finley yesterday I did a zoom
with him and he said he wants Dax to
play Joe exotic he said ax is the guy
who should play Joe huh
Derek deck oh yes he would be so
thrilled because he we loved that show
but there's one problem and he realized
it late the other night he has a an
actual massive fear of like killer
animals like we one time went to Africa
and he was very hesitant in the van to
even look out the window when we were on
safari watching the animals so he he
said that if they can figure out how to
do CG big cats
he said I'll play with a tiger but not
be doing any stunts with a 600-pound
animal he's not gonna hug you choose
he's not I would be all for it cuz I
trust animals I think they like me which
is probably a mistake but they can
figure out how to do it CG he's in he's
very much campaigning for the role I
think it would be brilliant I I mean I
literally was blown away because John
went right to it and and the interesting
part about it all is that he wants
that's to play that role and then he
wants Kane hate him he wants him hate
him to play him John Finley the guy who
had the shirt off did the interview
that's he by the way that's genius and
also you know Dax and Channing are very
good friends so they can pull this off
easily oh my god that he has to do it he
has to get right all right let's make it
let's make real it it
it's Greenland what was the thing that
made you guys craziest about it I mean I
have my my oldest son walks around
singing I saw Tiger all day long and
it's just bananas we need jobs axes
really good
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not him he didn't sing the songs
what yes he didn't sing the songs it's a
guy out of Washington State who did the
songs and he just lip-sync to them and
he sings over them crazy right
it gets even I mean the more you learn
about this the crazier it gets you just
took it to a whole new level for me
because I I was gonna give him credit
like oh well he's got a great voice and
he did he didn't write any of those
songs either I know this guy from
Washington State wrote the songs sung
them and then he hopped on and just sang
over them he made those songs for him
and his son came out first and then John
yesterday confirmed before us that yeah
he didn't sing those songs I I mean here
kitty-kitty come on
[Music]
I mean yeah it really made me feel like
I was in a different universe when I was
watching that show yeah yeah it did
it was it is something that is just
beyond anything you could dream up if
you may not be like that
you're crazy they'd be like too much a
universe where there's no rules you know
there's just this wow yeah okay and I'm
taking that in that he didn't actually
do the music okay I can believe it but
it's though it's crazy so it's also not
it's also like of course he didn't sing
them I know if you look at him it makes
sense that he was lip-syncing somebody
else's stuff yo you cool cats and
kittens it's Carolyn Big Cat Rescue do
you think Carol said her husband to the
Tigers I think the situation smells
fishy
yes but I don't know anything say it the
whole the whole series is very very
strange no it's beyond anything you
could ever make up it I love it
everybody is losing their mind about it
so I'm glad I could drop that a little
bit of knowledge about it I appreciate
all my lord
[Music]